as cryptographers our job is to try to
anticipate so let's say even if it is a
10 percent chance that in 10 years a
quantum computer will exist what they
represent to us is enough of a
catastrophe to invest big resources and
a lot of research and effort from the
global crypto community to try to solve
the problem just in case whatever the
case is we need to prepare for it you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it I'm your
host Gretchen Hughes Inga dr. Craig
Costello is in the business of
safeguarding your secrets and he uses
math to do it a researcher in the
security and cryptography group of
Microsoft Research
dr. Costello is among a formidable group
of code makers aka cryptographers who
make it their life's work to protect the
internet against adversarial code
breakers aka corrupt analysts both those
that exist today in our classical
computing world and those that will
exist in a quantum computing future on
today's podcast
dr. Costello gives us a battlefield
update in the ongoing crypto Wars talks
about different approaches to post
quantum cryptography and explains why he
believes I sahjhan T based primitives
are among the most promising and
reassures us that as long as the battle
goes on cryptographers will continue to
work very hard on the very hard math
they hope will protect us from hackers
and attackers even in the age of quantum
computers that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Craig Costello welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me your researcher on
the security and cryptography team at
Microsoft Research you're a
mathematician by training yep and by
your own description you say you're in
the business of safeguarding my secrets
first of all thanks now tell us how you
do that kind of broad strokes ten
thousand foot view and why but we'll get
you up in the morning I'd like to be
other sites for philanthropic saving the
world reasons but for me it's very very
simple I really love what I do since I
was very very young I've loved
mathematics and problem solving and so
in my adult life I'm very very lucky to
be able to say that I get to wake up and
do that every day the nice thing is that
the sorts of problems that I'm
interested in there's ways that they're
addressing real-world problems and the
other really nice thing for me is being
here at Microsoft Research I get to come
and work with like-minded people on
these problems every day so for me I'd
do it for fun but it's a really nice
result that we get to often if we're
doing our job well and if our group's
doing the right things then we get to
maybe have an impact on the real world
well so you say my secrets are safe with
you and I believe you up to a point and
and maybe not for long and we'll get to
that in a minute but let's set the stage
for that I want to talk about why right
now I feel confident sending my private
information over the Internet what's in
place now cryptographically speaking to
ensure my digital secrecy yeah okay so I
guess one thing that you should take
comfort in is that we know how to do
cryptography in a way that we're pretty
sure is and we'll get to this in a
minute what I mean classically secure we
know how to do encryption in a way that
we believe is secure even if an attacker
has all of the computing power on the
planet and they have the life age of the
universe to try to solve the problems
that your everyday encryption is based
on if it's implemented and done properly
and correctly then we at least believe
that the problems that you're
smartphones and laptops and computers
and all of your digital modern life is
based on our secure mhm
modern public key encryption allows us
to establish a secure channel even if
the physical channel that we're sending
information over is the Internet which
we assume is basically in the eyes of
the other 7 billion people on the planet
I guess the two cornerstones of public
key cryptography are digital signatures
and that's one way of me knowing that
it's you that I'm talking to right one
example that's I guess close to home is
if that little notification comes up in
the corner and says Microsoft would like
to install a software update and you
click accept one thing that you want to
know is that that software is indeed
coming from Microsoft some third party
sitting in the middle so digital
signatures is a mechanism that allows us
to verify mathematically that that
software does belong to the Microsoft
that I think it belongs to right and so
that's digital signatures that's one
side of the coin and then the other side
of the coin is key exchange or
encryption they kind of both achieve the
same high level goal and that is that
you and I having never met we can very
quickly establish a shared key I guess
more than 50 years ago we would have had
to have met up in person and I would
have had to hand you my key on paper or
you know my shared key on a USB but
nowadays we don't have to have met
before so there's this kind of
mathematical protocol or transaction
that takes place that allows you and I
to agree on a shared secret that we hope
with all of the computing power on the
planet nobody can possibly figure out
what that key was so the two kind of
cornerstones as you say of public key
cryptography are key exchange and
digital signatures backup is there any
other kind of cryptography that isn't
public key cryptography yeah good
question everything that's not public
key is what we call symmetric
cryptography so public key another term
for that is asymmetric cryptography and
that's based on the fact that we don't
start out sharing any okay and and then
there's symmetric cryptography which is
how cryptography started which is you
and I both start out maybe in the same
room we hand each other a piece of paper
that we can use as a shared key and then
we can go to the other side of the world
and theoretically exchange message
using that shared key but nowadays in
modern encryption we still use both we
use public key to establish that shared
key so we use key exchange to do that
and we use digital signatures to be sure
that it's the right person that I'm
talking to and then once we establish
that shared key we feed it into the
old-school symmetric key algorithms to
do things much more efficiently
interesting all right so of those two
cornerstones you fall on one particular
Rock so I guess my research in the last
five years has certainly been in the key
exchange realm of things one real-world
justification I guess for focusing more
on key exchanges there's a subtle
difference between the models of
security you might consider in key
exchange and signatures so if we're
talking about signatures you and I
really only need to worry about the
adversary that exists today right now if
you send me your digital signature as
soon as I verify that it's yours then
I'm done with the signature I know that
today that was you and I'm talking to
you in key exchange it's a little
different you and I will establish a
shared key with a key exchange mechanism
and then you and I will use that shared
key to send a lot of secret data to one
another the difference in the key
exchange model is that we might want to
worry about attackers that don't just
exist today but they might exist in the
future one thing that people that worry
about key exchange have to worry about
is not just the best attacks in the
world today but what attackers might
come tomorrow or 10 years down the line
or 20 years down the line however long
we want our digital information to be
secured for we have to kind of try to
anticipate and guess what attackers
might read their heads in and it used to
come you've said in a very entertaining
TED talk that cryptographers are the
first line of defense in the war between
code makers and code breakers so give us
a brief history of this war Craig who
has historically been winning and what
changed in the 20th century to give
cryptographers a decisive advantage the
two examples that I saw it in the talk
are ones that there's being a few movies
made about both I guess so hey so I
watch
the mom yeah I guess one of the first
kind of sighted uses of cryptography was
Queen Mary of the Scots Way back in the
1600s
she was conspiring against Queen
Elizabeth the first to actually arrange
an assassination to take back her
leadership of England and Scotland and
she was sending messages out of prison
and obviously she couldn't trust any of
the middlemen so what she was doing was
using what we call a substitution cipher
I guess the most basic cipher you could
think of it what I remembered trying to
send notes around in primary school so
exactly so I'm gonna always replace the
letter A with the letter X and instead
of the letter B I'll replace the letter
B with the letter K so you might think
of some permutation of the alphabet or
different symbols that you might replace
the letters with right and so that was I
guess one of the first uses of
cryptography but it was very soon shown
to be insecure in fact Queen Elizabeth
had code breakers that what they ended
up doing was some version of what we
call frequency analysis so if you look
at the English language you know that
the most common letter is e yeah so all
her code breakers had to do was look for
the most common symbol and then go okay
maybe that's going to be an e and we'll
try and try hangman and wheel of fortune
and so very soon that became something
that we wouldn't want to do and then
things progressed from there and over
the last four to five centuries this
race between that is writing the codes
the code makers or the cryptographers
and the code breakers or the Crypt
analysts it's going back and forth
between both sides so cryptographers
will improve their encryption techniques
and then the code breakers they get to
work and find out ways to break it and
the second example I cited in the talk
was about the Enigma code that the Nazis
used in World War two they use these
complicated machines with the squillions
of different combinations of how the
rotors could be set up and changing them
every day and then on the other side
were the British codebreakers led by
Alan Turing and a bunch of others at
GCHQ that were trying to break the
Enigma code but again the Germans had to
have a secret key that they shared every
day and they had to exchange the secret
key in advance so they had these massive
code books of daily keys that they would
use and of course if those code books
fell into
the hands of the Allies then they would
be able to tune their own enigma
machines to decrypt the codes which they
did do but also Alan Turing was working
with his team and he built a machine
he's also the same guy that invented the
modern computer right but he built a
machine and used it to break the Enigma
code and so very soon we kind of
discovered that symmetric or at least
historically we can look back and think
that symmetric cryptography doesn't
really solve the problem of parties
having to share a secret key in advance
okay so that was in the 40s yeah things
have come even further from that
absolutely so I think that the lesson in
all those historical ciphers is that the
problem of having to share a secret key
it doesn't really scale now and
certainly it doesn't scale to what we
now know as having to protect the
internet and so nowadays to protect the
internet and to protect these billions
of you know interactions between parties
all over the place that are happening
every second we need something that
scales one good thing was that this
notion of public key cryptography
arrived I suppose just in time for the
internet in the 70s the invention of
public key cryptography came along and
that's the celebrated diffie-hellman
protocol that allows us to do key
exchange public key cryptography is kind
of a notion that sits above however you
try to instantiate it so public key
cryptography is a way of doing things
and how you choose to do them or what
mathematical problem you might base it
on I guess is how you instantiate public
key cryptography so initially the two
proposals that were proposed back in the
70s were what we call the discrete log
problem in finite field when you compute
powers of numbers and you do them in a
finite field you might start with a
number and compute some massive power of
it and then give someone the residue or
the remainder of that number and say
what was the power that I raised this
number to in the group and the other
problem is factorization so integer
factorization so you might be able to
take any two numbers you like and
multiply them on a computer and and a
computer could essentially multiply any
two numbers you like no matter how big
they are and come up with the answer
exactly but if I gave you the answer for
and said what were those two numbers and
now you don't have to choose one and the
number itself that's cheating yeah
they've got to be the two the two bigger
the prime long times 851 yeah that's one
solution to the factorization but it's
not the one we're looking for we're
looking for the two large prime numbers
that multiply and give the large
composite number so these kind of two
proposals were initially really the
foundations on which public cryptography
were built and so nowadays we use those
all the time so we use you and I on your
laptop and on my smartphone these
factorization and discrete log problems
are built in to our everyday lives
without us knowing so when you send a
text message if it's using a secure
protocol you're probably multiplying two
numbers together or computing some
exponentiation in a discrete group and
let's stay in the 20th century for a
minute but move over to a different
scientific field of physics
more specifically quantum physics
Michael and the bunch of 20th century
physicists who came to the cryptography
party inspect the punch bowl tell us
about the wacky world of quantum physics
quantum mechanics and quantum computing
first of all why is it promising and how
is it keeping cryptographers busy today
quantum physics is this braid of physics
that differs from classical physics so
as humans we have a very good handle on
classical physics so we know what
trajectory we might have to send a
rocket up in space to land on the moon
and we know why our planets orbit the
Sun in ellipses in the way that they do
and we've got a good handle on all the
things that as humans we can see and
observe an experiment on quantum physics
is really what's going on at the tiniest
level that we can now observe that we
couldn't observe back in the days of
Newton and Galileo and so on
so at the beginning of the 20th century
as scientists started to think about
what was happening at the subatomic
level so the level of electrons and
protons and subatomic particles these
new problems started to rear their heads
and we realized that all of the things
we thought about the motion of planets
and things they don't really apply it
that subatomic level there's a lot more
weird and wacky behavior happening down
there where quantum computing comes in
is heading towards the end of the 20th
century when physicists and those with
access to classical computers they were
trying to simulate what molecules and
particles are doing if you're trying to
simulate a complex molecule and you add
just one electron to a molecule that's
already very complex in nature you add
one electron and that electron might
either be spin up or spin down that
electrons interactions with all of the
other electrons in the particle to
simulate that it requires that you
double the number of possibilities so
every time you might add an electron you
might double the storage required all
the computation that you need to
simulate that molecule on a classical
computer right so very very quickly
these simulations become exponential in
size certainly exponential in terms of
what a classical computer can handle and
simulate and so the genius idea that
kind of sparked quantum computing
Richard Feynman and David Deutsch and
others started to think okay if this
quantum behavior is so complex and so
difficult to simulate classically maybe
we can flip it around and use this crazy
behavior to do computation for us now it
sounds like a very ingenious and clever
way to look at things to look at it the
reverse way but the real problem with
quantum computing is being able to
actually engineer these behaviors in the
real world
[Music]
let's talk about how it relates to you
in cryptography right now and the math
behind quantum code making and code
breaking people speculate when we're
gonna have a functional cryptographic
irrelevant quantum computer but nobody
ever says if yeah I've heard everywhere
from 30 years to a few years to
quote-unquote they secretly already
existed it's not telling us right but
you said the more relevant point is that
regardless of where we are in that time
line that it might already be too late
yeah exactly
I'm sorry yes I should say that I don't
really have any authority to comment
when I think a quantum computer will
exist as I said I'm not a physicist no
one can for sure say one way or the
other and even those who are really
skeptical and say no they're fifty years
off at least or they might never exist
they can't say that with certainty and I
think it's cryptographers our job is to
try to anticipate so let's say even if
it is a 10 percent chance that in 10
years one will exist what they represent
to us is enough of a catastrophe to
invest big resources and a lot of
research and effort from the global
crypto community to try to solve the
problem just in case whatever the case
is we need to prepare for it that's what
our research is doing is to try to look
to ways to quantum proof our you know
key exchange in digital signatures are
now now public key crypto so that we can
keep doing all the things that we're
currently doing but when a quantum
computer or if a quantum computer comes
along or already exists that we can do
them in a way that the quantum threat is
mitigated right so you know I can see
that extrapolating out into the future
and it could be years it could be
decades it could be a century who knows
or Never but let's say it's gonna happen
right what's happening now that should
make me concerned we might anticipate
that an attacker might not have the
resources or the money to build a
quantum computer today it might just be
too infeasible based on the engineering
and the physics of the problem but they
certainly might have the budget to have
a big data storage center to be able to
store enough of today's secret traffic
it's cheap enough to do that into wait
until the day comes we're building a
quantum computer is doable enough or
doable at all so that they can get their
hands on one and so one thing that we're
worried about is attackers that are
already anticipating this possibility
and storing today's traffic and waiting
for that quantum computer to come down
the line if you anyone like me I guess
you think I'll what would I possibly be
doing today that anyone cares to me yeah
in 10 years time I mean I probably won't
care if someone reads my emails in 10
years time or maybe been on Twitter
Melies or maybe my own credit card
numbers will have changed by then and I
don't have to worry but if you look at
military organizations and economic
entities that need their trade secrets
and their classified data to remain
secure you know decades into the future
then matters yeah it matters now because
if there is that 50% chance that a
quantum computer exists in 15 years then
there's a 50% chance that they're going
to be in trouble if they don't well
figure it out today
yeah and your colleague Brian LaMacchia
also was on the podcast and he referred
to it as record now break later or
record now and exploit later yeah
exactly the interactive breaks so then
without giving the bad guys a tactical
advantage Craig what are you doing to
quantum proof my information now I
should back up and say that the reason
we have to do all of this is because
those two problems I spoke about earlier
the two that were chosen in the 70s to
instantiate public key cryptography it
just so happens that there was this
algorithm that was published in the 90s
called shields algorithm and I believe
both Brian and crystal a famous guy he
already developed this algorithm that
said you know if a quantum computer
exists then here's the algorithm you can
use to break the integer factorization
problem but more generally what we call
the hidden subgroup problem and so it's
both integer factorization and the
discrete logarithm problem they fall
under the umbrella of this more general
problem that sure the algorithm can
solve with a quantum computer so it just
so happens that the two things with the
teams back in the seventies chose to
instantiate public key cryptography will
turned out to be
instances of something that's easy to
break with a quantum computer now of
course they couldn't have foreseen this
because quantum computing as a topic
didn't even exist then right and we
don't have one that can do this yet not
yet at least not at the sizes that we
care about all the sizes that you and I
are sending around when we send our
traffic over the internet let's talk
about that for one second because I do
want to establish even today there's one
company that has a 53 qubit quantum
computer that's accessible online and
another one boasts like a 72 qubit yeah
but nobody's using it it's very much an
in-house thing right what would you say
the number of qubits we need to be
worried about is it's a question that a
lot of researchers are looking into and
there's been papers from members of our
team and others here at Microsoft
Research that are trying to get a handle
on how many qubits we'd need to break
the kind of cryptography that you and I
are using if you look at the qubit
growth that these companies are
announcing in you know in the last
decade or so a lot of people who know
more about the physics than I do say
it's not the right metric to be looking
at but certainly in the news that's the
thing that we look at you know every
other day there's someone saying no I've
got 75 qubits know I've got 81 qubits
whatever it is then I think these papers
that came out of a team here and some
other teams around the place have said
you know to break the discrete log
problem or the elliptic curve discrete
log problem or integer factorization
you're going to need somewhere on the
magnitude of thousands fault-tolerant
qubits so these are qubits that are very
stable under those you know crazy
physical conditions we were talking
about earlier and so it seems like
unless there's a big explosion which
could happen any day where someone
figures out a way to scale this up and I
know that there's researchers here and
all around the place trying to do that
but until that happens the numbers that
we use are still kind of out of the
reach of these machines that are already
there so it's not right now this is just
the ramping up to get something and
fault-tolerant is a key word here
because there as we said pretty unstable
absolutely well talk a little bit Craig
about the kinds of problems then that
even quantum couldn't break and the
kinds of things you're working on in the
wacky wacky math world of you know yes
dimension geometric numbers you call
them abstract and exotic yeah
tell us about this space right now the
reason I say that abstract and exotic
because a lot of these math problems
come from the field of abstract algebra
in looking at post quantum cryptography
we're looking for mathematical problems
that still do the same functionality
that we already used today public key
crypto so we still want to be able to do
key exchange in digital signatures as I
said it just turns out that the two math
problems we use to do that both fall
victim to Shor's algorithm so what we're
looking for is other mathematical
problems that do the same thing but
maybe don't fall victim to Shor's
algorithm or to any other quantum
algorithm that we know we'd like to be
able to say yes their quantum secure all
of these problems that we're looking at
it could turn out that they're not even
classically secure it could turn out
that RSA and the discrete log problem
aren't classically secure it's just that
we've been trying to break them for 40
years and have had no success so the
only thing we do know is that if we have
a quantum computer though we can break
those so we definitely if we're
anticipating a quantum computer needs
some new problem no you're not quantum
security yes but some of these proposals
for post quantum crypto have been around
almost as long as public key
cryptography itself so there's these
proposals based on the mcLeese crypto
system which is using error correcting
codes which for those in the know it's
kind of like you're doing large linear
algebra over the binary field so just
big matrices of zeros and ones with a
lot of equations in a lot of unknowns
and you just add some error to these big
linear equations and all of a sudden
it's very very hard to solve and so
these problems have been around and they
could have been chosen back in the 70s
or maybe the 80s to do public key crypto
it's just that we were already pretty
happy with factorization in discrete
logs and they seemed enough yeah and we
didn't know about the quantum world yet
so there's problems that have been
around for a while that we've got a lot
of confidence in and also it just turns
out that when we look at those problems
and try to attack them with the quantum
computer
there's nothing we've found yet that is
like Shor's algorithm to
factorization and so on so there's also
lattices so lattices is from a high
level just like codes the way we do it
in cryptography you've got a lot of
equations in a lot of unknowns you're
kind of doing linear algebra with error
again so if you have a big linear system
that you're trying to solve if there's
no error we know how to do that very
quickly but as soon as you add a little
bit of error then these problems become
very hard and and when I say we're using
big matrices you're trying to solve
these problems and it turns out that's
there's a lot of work that's being done
that shows that if you're going to try
to solve one of these hard problems in
many dimensions then it's at least as
hard as trying to break lattice problems
in that many dimensions define how many
dimensions we're talking about so we're
talking about a lot more than two or
three dimensions like a lot more than we
can draw in this three or four
dimensional world or in a two
dimensional pieces of paper we're
talking 500 plus one of the ones that
our team is involved in is a thousand
and twenty four dimensions how do you
even wrap your brain around that once
you get beyond three or four dimensions
you and I would find it very hard to
picture so I can write geometrically
picture that in my head but the way you
jump from two to three dimensions on a
piece of graph paper you numerically can
represent how you do that and then you
just keep adding dimension see your
matrices go from a two by two or a three
by three matrix to a thousand by
thousand matrix which we can still write
down easily in store but it's just hard
to picture in a three or four
dimensional world yeah yeah all right so
let's go a little further you talked
about lattice space are there other
approaches to this and what's being done
now and where do you land in the hole
right so party yes I there's about four
or five really popular I guess avenues
of Investigation okay at the moment and
so lattices and codes are definitely two
of the popular ones and the lattices
have been used for key exchange and
digital signatures and codes does key
encapsulation - then there's hash based
so hash functions are something that
we've had lying around for decades as
well and there's now public key digital
signature algorithms that are based on
Merkle trees which is kind of a way of
instantiate encase signature proposal
and then there's two more that are
really popular multivariate quadratic
equations is one hard problem that
people are constructing digital
signatures on and then the fifth one is
based on elliptic curve isogen ease so
one of the proposals that our team is
looking into is this super singular is
our journey based cryptography or s idh
so super singular so Janine
diffie-hellman is what SRD h stands for
and we've built this library that does
this that people can take and test and
use to do hopefully post quantum secure
key exchange but underneath that is hard
problems based on what's called the
super singular so Janine problem it's
been studied since the 90s but really
only used in the last decade or so to
build cryptography nowadays we're a lot
more interested in how we might try to
break them both classically and
quantumly right and what we could use
them for where is that research now I
mean how confident are you and what
you're because you're making some big
bets here yeah exactly so so that well
this is the thing this is the funny game
we're playing so I guess with isogen is
it's the newer one in my very biased
opinion it's the coolest one because it
uses the the coolest math I guess in the
pre quantum crypto
that there another way that public key
crypto has been instantiated classically
using a single elliptic curve to do
discrete log base key exchange or
signatures the difference with the post
quantum version is that we're not using
one fixed elliptic curve anymore we're
using exponentially many elliptic curves
that are all connected in what we call
the super signal our sahjhan your graph
and so this jumping around between many
elliptic curves the way that you do that
is called an ISO Janee so it's a group
homomorphism between two nodes in this
graph and at the moment we think that
jumping far enough away from you know
you're starting with an elliptic curve
that is a node in this graph and you
compute it enough jumps that you believe
that for an attacker to find out what
that path was we believe that it's it's
hard even if the attacker has a quantum
computer so that's the bet we're making
but I should back up and say that with
all of these bets there's no way we can
be sure their quantum secure that's for
sure but there's no way we can even be
sure that they're classically secure
right
really encrypt though what we try to do
and is to leave these things around and
make them pass the test of time and so
once enough brainy crypt analysts have
tried to break it unsuccessfully and
there's been you know no progress or
very little progress then we start to
think okay these things are hard enough
to you know actually ship and to do our
cryptography on well let's go back to
these hard problems that you proposed I
want to talk about that world for a
minute because NIST which stands for the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology
they say they promote innovation and
industrial competitiveness across a
broad spectrum of technologies and
endeavors yeah it includes cybersecurity
and that's a place where they have
competitions in this cat-and-mouse game
so tell me what you're doing there and
what you and your team have submitted
yes so um well first of all they started
out but calling it a standardization
process rather than a competition but
very quickly even in their own talks
needs to be like okay everyone's trying
to break everyone else's and this is
let's just be real this is a competition
and everyone wants this game to be the
one that uh that survives again
standardized yeah exactly so there was I
think 69 submissions across key exchange
and digital signatures from all around
the world and our team here Brian's team
our security and cryptography team we
were involved in four of those
submissions so we had two digital
signature algorithms
they're called picnic which is based on
zero knowledge proof sand symmetric
cryptography and then there's Q Tesla
which is a lattice based signature
scheme so there are two signature
schemes and then on the key exchange
side there's Frodo which is one of these
lattice based submissions so this is the
thousand and twenty four dimensional a
lot of space scheme that some of my
colleagues have been involved in
proposing and pursuing and then there's
this super singer or ISO Jenny
diffie-hellman or or super single ISO
Janicki encapsulation and it's called
psych and that's the one that that I've
been working with some members of our
team and some teams around the world
we're kind of driving that ISO journey
based submission so when you put them
into this petition yep how do they
assess how do they this is the fight
well so
what happened initially so these 70
submissions were proposed and then I
think in the first week somewhere
between like 10 or 20 of them fell take
a cricket bat yeah absolutely and so
teams were like the day that there are
announced and posted teams were already
trying to break everyone else's and so
very quickly the ones that had flaws
although were insecure or they were just
based on bad math problems they kind of
fell and then at this stage 26 of the 70
odd submissions
have progressed around 2 and so the four
that we proposed in our team have
fortunately progressed to that second
stage so we're still in the running to
keep trying to push these submissions
forward as far as optimizing them and
investigating their security so that's
whether the state of the the nist
process is right now it sounds like a
giant case of last math standing yeah
exactly right that's and I think that's
how it should be
[Music]
this is the part of the podcast where I
usually ask what keeps you up at night
yeah and I think we've actually covered
quite a bit of what can keep us up at
night but let me just ask because I
can't let a podcast go by without asking
what does keep you up at night and I
know that again we've talked about so
many things you cryptographers are
people who worry about things yeah
cryptographers generally we tend to be
conspiracy theorists and people that are
kept up at night worrying about
attackers and hackers I I myself don't
lose too much sleep every day because of
those problems I think for me it's the
very specific technical scientific
challenges is what literally keeps me up
at night it's what I love doing and so I
I like to stay away to try to solve
problems which is something I've always
loved doing ultimately and hopefully if
this research that our groups involved
in and that this worldwide initiative is
involved in pushing forward if it does
turn out to save the day then maybe just
maybe that'll help me sleep better might
make me go to sleep earlier but until
then no I'm kind of fascinated with the
technical details and then every now and
then you come up for breath but yeah I I
can't say myself I lose too much sleep
thinking about the hackers or the threat
of quantum computers I'm certainly
excited about the positive aspects and
I'm excited at what they've done for our
field which is hopefully one doesn't
exist and they've shaken off our
research field enough for us to have all
these juicy problems to look at and then
hopefully we solve the problem in time
and everyone can still do secure
communications and encryption before
they arrive well tell us a little about
yourself Craig I can tell by your accent
that you're not from here and also you
told me you were Australian so yeah yeah
how did you wind up doing cryptography
research at Microsoft Research in
Redmond yeah so I came to do a year of
my PhD in California on a scholarship at
University of California in Irvine
so UCI and then I was an intern I came
here for a summer internship I guess I
came through the kind of usual route of
being a research intern here and then I
came back the next year knocking on the
door again for another one and then
basically I've never left I then became
a postdoc and I loved it so much that I
don't see myself leaving any fights they
drag you by your feet yeah yeah and who
did you work with in your internship I
was there's two crypto teams here at
Microsoft Research so during my
internships I worked with Kristen Lauda
and her cryptography research team and
then I was in Kristin's team with my
postdoc and since then became a
full-time researcher in Brian LaMacchia
security and crypto group as we close
and this has been delightful thanks for
doing what would you say to aspiring
researchers who might be interested in
working on cryptography in a post
quantum world what's next in the crypto
Wars and who do you need in your
battalion oh good question
um who do we need in our battalion is a
fantastic way to put it because the one
thing I really like about this field of
cryptography is it's very kind of
multidisciplinary whether you're coming
from a computer science background and
you know nothing about mathematics or
physics or whether you're coming from a
mathematics background or quantum
physics background all of those
backgrounds would be very useful in
crypto it helps to have a broad interest
across I guess the spectrum but it
doesn't matter where you're coming from
cryptography could use someone from any
one of those fields or for all the
others I have one more question what two
numbers multiply do equal 8 yes that's I
think it's 1 times I don't know I'm
chaining that that one was from what
talk it's 23 times 37 but um yeah it was
that if you gave me any other number
that was about the same size I'll have
to sit here for a second you know I
thought that was the point of it is that
you'd have to sit there for more than a
second yeah Craig Costello
it's been so fun thank you for coming in
and talking about math with us thanks
Amy pleasure
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Craig Costello
and how researchers are working to keep
your online secret safe both now and in
the quantum future visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]